normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Alx on
Twitter says Taylor the ren says she's
being shadowbanned on threads and then a
laughing crying Emoji now for those of
you that are aren't familiar Taylor
Duren is a very prominent mainstream
media reporter she's worked for a bunch
of uh very large Publications very
critical of Elon Musk very left leaning
now she like many other woke reporters
left Twitter compl laining that Elon
Musk was going to make it riddled with
hate speech or whatever but now she has
these threads up on threads of all
places complaining that she is being
censored let me just tell you we're
going over uh you know our content you
know uh production and everything and
what we want to do and we want to do
sketches and jokes we're working on the
skateboarding show and uh I'm like you
know we can put whatever we want on X we
can go on X we can make any joke we want
no matter how vulgar or whatever and
Rumble too but Facebook will get banned
Tik Tok will get banned and Instagram
will get banned that's obvious to anyone
with a brain so all of these woke
journalists that thought they were going
to rush over to threads and are now
complaining about it surprise surprise
she posted I posted the cover of
yesterday's New York Post to threads
talking about how hypothetical I'm sorry
how how hypocritical the New York Post
is in their criticism of meta when they
published the same for thinspo images
their bashing metaphor I don't know what
she's referring to what did threads do
locked me out of my Instagram account
until I deleted the thread and sent this
message to my account saying they're
going to shadowban me absolutely insane
levels of censorship where we can't even
discuss the media's coverage of meta on
meta's own apps well on Twitter you can
talk about whatever you want how are we
supposed to critique Media or cover the
media when meta essentially bans all
discussions on of certain stories and
topics it's terrible for free expression
and I wish more people in the media held
meta to account for their dangerously
blunt moderation tactics what I
absolutely love about this is that this
is this tweet could have been from six
years ago on Twitter from someone on the
right and now it's coming from a woke
reporter who is on Mark Zuckerberg's
threads and she did not have to leave
Twitter like things have gotten so much
better so let me just say this is I mean
I guess it's shot and Freud that's kind
of funny that's why Alex is posting the
laughing emoji to see Taylor the ren be
like oh no I'm being censored it's like
well that kind of proves our point right
others are probably just gloating in her
being censored but uh I think it's a
good sign and I think it shows you how
important it was that Elon Musk took the
actions that he did it proves him right
it kind of reminds me of the reverse of
when people who are liberal and live in
big cities move to small towns and then
want to change it like she was somewhere
that had free speech left it and now
it's like but why is there no free
speech this is crazy I mean I don't
think Zuckerberg promised anyone
anything other than to sell all your
data to China and that's my personal
opinion I think I I think uh well I'll
just go as conspiratorial as possible I
think threads is probably uh intelligent
us intelligence agencies it's just feds
I totally forgot it existed but to your
point this always like cracks me up I
guess like Alx because I love when like
this sort of thing happens to leftist
right because it's the monster that they
created coming for them they were
totally fine with the revolution until
they became the target Taylor Ren I
think the Twitter files showed reported
more accounts than practically any other
user on the platform she was a champion
for the censorship cause and now it's
it's coming for her and I I think it's
hilarious to watch so also this phenomen
on where people will go from system to
system to system and they'll see the
same problem in every system but they'll
go like this system's broken some who's
who's in charge of this system fix it
they go to the next one this system's
broken who's in charge of this fix it
but what they don't see is the pattern
yeah it would have been interesting if
she had been like as an experiment I
posted this thing to see how meta would
respond to it and they have censored me
and therefore meta doesn't like whatever
but instead it's like I am the victim
this system is not helping me the way I
think it should it's not obeying my
desires even though it never agreed to
give me meet these things in the first
place it's only worse Instagram's way
worse and the funny thing is when
conservatives and Libertarians came out
and said yeah yeah threads is way worse
we all tried it the leftist media
organizations came out and and accused
all of us of being conspiracy theorists
and lying and making these stories up
and now they're they're reaping what
they've sown they all jumped onto this I
mean look X Twitter whatever is this
massive and there's concerns about
whether or not there's going to be
enough fuel for it because all these are
pulling out fine but Mark Zuckerberg
pulls up on this dinging he's like
everybody up all everybody hop on board
and they're all like yeah and they all
jump onto this little dingy that Mark
Zuckerberg's driving around in and it
doesn't work and now and this is what we
get so I don't know I guess people can
Revel in shoden Freud or whatever but uh
going back to what I was saying I think
it's deep State I think uh we can say a
few things that are absolutely Fair one
it is not a conspiracy it's actually a
fact it is historical record us
intelligence agencies were in direct
communication with all of the big tech
companies running social media to
manipulate and control speech there this
was directly related to the hunter Biden
laptop interfering with elections that's
how extreme it was I was personally
targeted by the government and uh
leftist uh uh tactics with the um what
is it was it the EIC was it or was it
EIP election it was EIP right election
Integrity partnership or something where
they tried getting people banned and
taking things down and they did
successfully do this government
colluding with um researchers they call
them researchers this is how they can
launder government censorship we know
for a fact they're doing it okay then
Elon Musk says he's going to buy X and
he's and he's going to you know there's
talk of restoring all these accounts
bringing people back and uh oh deep
State's going to get exposed
intelligence agencies did get exposed at
the exact same time this is going down
Mark Zuckerberg announces threads simple
solution is that Zuckerberg said hey I
got a great opportunity to make a a
competitor right now to Twitter and all
these people who are mad elon's buying
it we can give them space he created a
Canada equivalent yeah and and that's
and that's a simple explanation and now
I'll give you the simple conspiratorial
explanation which I believe is extremely
likely to be true upon announcing this
the CIA the FBI uh Biden Administration
contacted Mark Zuckerberg because they
were already in direct communication and
said we definitely want to be able to
access threads in the same way as
everything else and Zuck probably said
don't worry it'll function the same as
other platforms you will have access and
that's where we are now there's the the
Bolder more less likely conspir
conspiracy in that the Deep State
directly went to Zuckerberg and said you
got to do something about this you need
to make some kind of competitor can you
do it I would not be surprised to be
honest to find out that someone in
government went to Zuckerberg and
suggested it not that they demanded it
or mandated it but I wouldn't be
surprised if some emails got released
through a Foy request something where it
shows someone in the Biden White House
said hey Mark are you able to make
something because you know this Twitter
stuff is bad and then Zuckerberg said
yes I think it's arrogance on
Zuckerberg's part though to think that
his uh technology and what he would
build would be able to compete with
Twitter SLX or whatever it was called at
the time I mean people are really
devoted to Twitter as a platform it was
revolutionary in what it was creating
and I think that original medium we've
seen other people I mean there's truth
social there are a couple other
competitors out there that just haven't
been able to achieve it and so to think
oh well because it's already connected
to your Instagram account therefore
somehow that will convert people I think
just shows how out of touch or how under
how much he underestimated uh X and
elon's ability to retain loyal
supporters it's like goog plus remember
that for like a second but I forgot what
it was and they had Hangouts was that a
thing yeah Hangouts Hangouts were
actually pretty big for a while they
were and it's yeah go+ wasn't but
Hangouts were because it was the easiest
way to do a a web-based live chat with
multiple people now it's all Zoom or
whatever but if Google made Hangouts and
and and kept pushing that people
wouldn't be doing Zoom meetings they'd
be doing Hangouts yeah cuz that that's
what a lot of people were doing but they
just had to get that pandemic earlier
only only you know the thing about
Google is they just don't understand how
to be cool so what happens is everyone's
pissed at Facebook so Google+ announces
you know we're making a social platform
and everybody wanted it but they said no
no no no no limited users only sent out
a bunch of invites tons of people signed
up I actually had what did I have I had
like
500,000 followers on go+ yeah weird
weird they totally Mis mismanaged
YouTube they should have made YouTube
The Social Network calling it Google
Plus and Google Hangout and Google this
and that and they tried doing that you
had YouTube they tried doing that and it
was killing YouTube so anyway what they
should have done at this point with
Google+ was as soon as the demand was at
maximum capacity and everybody wanted an
invite they should have said I'm sorry
everyone it's an exclusive platform only
and then 2 hours later said you know
what we're opening it up baby and then
they would have they would have won
instantly they did the same thing with
Google Glass they they launched
something everybody wants it and then
they say nah you can't have it and then
eventually some woke journalist goes
well I didn't want it anyway you're a
glasshole and then all of a sudden
nobody wants to buy Google Glass anymore
it went from the coolest thing everybody
wanted to just total garbage yeah I I
had some faith when Google bought
YouTube that it would be I mean they
they were able to start funding it with
the partner program which is pretty cool
but like Larry and Sergey are like uber
nerds you know so the company's kind of
like uber nerdy just the way it was
built the I like them but they were
nerdy there was a period I think it was
um let's see what year would it have
been maybe like
2013 or 14 I'm not sure no it was
probably way earlier than that Google
was trying to integrate YouTube and goog
plus they wanted they wanted Google
YouTube to turn into go+ and when they
started integrating it people started
fleeing and complaining like crazy and
so then they backed off was like they
had three stops you could either go to
Google+ you could go to your Google
Hangout which was connected to your
Google phone number or was it to your
other Google account I had three of them
you know three different emails attached
to three different accounts and I
couldn't get them to consolidate it was
such a mess I can understand why these
platforms want to grow and become more
things they have to compete I mean the
same ways that Instagram added reals
this the short form video to directly
compete with t Tik Tok that makes sense
to me they're more similar but I don't
understand and maybe it's because and I
don't know if anyone in this room can
answer it I don't understand the point
of threads I've never opened it and I'm
not sure how it differentiates from the
YouTube like Community tab don't isn't
that what threads is like Twitter yeah
is like Twitter but then YouTube has the
community tab right like isn't that
where people can message if they're like
really into a Creator or whatever like
no that's that's that's kind of like a
Twitter feed for your YouTube but it's
basically linked to your YouTube so it's
used to uh for the most part hey guys
heads up announcements see I I feel like
it would make more sense to me to have
an integ graded competitor to X on
YouTube because people are already alive
and well in the comment sections there
to make a competitor on Instagram seems
weird to me I just opened threads and
the first thing I see I've got um let's
see Michaela Peterson and then uh
Charlie Kirk and there's two replies to
Charlie Kirk's post it's buing over
there ter I don't know Charlie Charlie
why are you using threads you should
make our threads right now Kingsley I
bet you could be the most dominant
person by the end of the episode there
we go oh okay I think Michaela Michaela
Peterson's responding to a bunch of
people criticizing her
dad it's exhilarating because all the
lefties went there though it's just like
a cesspool of like it's an echo chamber
in many ways and I feel like the fun
Parts about Twitter about YouTube are
like fighting in the comments and like
seeing people dunk on other people like
that's why I love Twitter I think that's
why a lot of people love Twitter so when
you take that away you just lose the
user experience unless they start
infighting which could be interesting
who checked threads during the outbreak
of the Hamas Israel conflict cuz maybe
it was was like alive and well then oh I
forgot to check my threads that's why
cuz that's when I think a lot of the
left was up in arms not that it wasn't
true on the right but that was a
particularly challenging times for like
the most Progressive angle of the party
versus the more moderate side uh they
were fighting a lot I wonder if threads
allowed any kind of discontent I don't
trust proprietary software in general
but I really don't trust public
companies when they do social networks
like X is private still at this I'm
pretty sure X is still private and mines
is private you have Rumble well Rumble
just went public
but that's like road to co-op thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net